19:36 and king george v is dead
well almost he was dying in fact he was
actually taking a bit too long to die in
so his doctor was sure to inject him
with lethal amounts of both cocaine and
morphine the reason why this was done
was so that the King's death could be
announced in the much more respectable
morning papers instead of the evening
ones he was succeeded by his eldest son
Edward who became Edward the eighth
Edwards ascension to the throne wasn't
actually guaranteed his father had
reservations about him and hope that he
would abdicate the right to succeed in
favor of his brother Prince Albert the
reason why was the Edward was a fairly
scandalous chap who refused to settle
down and kept having affairs with
married women such as a certain Wallis
Simpson so upon taking the throne Edward
tried to be a good monarch and he poured
a lot of efforts into the governing of
the United Kingdom and the British
Empire the problem he had was that he
was extremely opinionated and Kings are
supposed to be neutral for example when
Germany illegally Rhee militarized the
Rhineland against the terms of the
Treaty of Versailles the British
government condemned the action it would
promptly lambasted the government for
doing so because he liked Germany and
Hitler the government could put up with
a nosy King but in November of 1936
Edward declared that he was going to
marry Simpson this was a big no-no why
we're the first reason was obvious she
was still married the second was that
even if she did get a divorce the Church
of England until our people to remarry
if their ex-spouse ha's were alive the
fact that Simpson had already been to
force once before by this point also
made people worried that she was only
interested in the Kings money or his
titles Stanley Baldwin the prime
minister urged the king to ditch Simpson
before his reputation and that of the
monarchy was damaged you see the press
had been quiet about Edward's affair
with Simpson for the first 10 months of
his reign largely out of respect and to
prevent embarrassment but overseas it
was common knowledge
Edward reluctantly tried for a
compromise a morganatic marriage this
would mean that if they were to be
married Simpson wouldn't become Queen
and any children that they had wouldn't
be entitled to succeed the throne in
late November of 1936 Baldwin and the
rest of the government refused to
support any kind of marriage it was
clear that there would be no compromise
in two sides formed those dedicated to
keeping Simpson off the throne led by
Baldwin and Cosmo Gordon Lang the
Archbishop of Canterbury and those who
wanted him to stay known as the Kings
party this included members such as
Winston Churchill the former Liberal
prime Minister David Lloyd George and
Oswald Mosley the leader of the British
Union of fascists in terms of public
opinion many were actually very
sympathetic to the king but Simpson
wasn't very
pila and many didn't want an American on
the throne the efforts of the king and
his supporters came to nothing and so
Edward opted to abdicate which he did on
December the 10th 1936 the throne passed
to his brother Albert who became King
George the sixth Edward was made the
Duke of Windsor married Simpson in 1937
and they stayed together until Edward's
death in 1972 I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching a
special thanks to Winston Cawood James
Bissonnette Ozark a flash Henry Robin
Adam Harvey and Skye Chappell if you'd
like to learn more about Edward the
eighth and the application crisis there
are some book recommendations in the
description below